>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
WHEN THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
INVADED UKRAINE, THE MOST HIGHLY
CREDENTIALED PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
SEEMED STUNNED BY IT.
THAT WAS NOT VERY REASSURING TO
THE REST OF US.
WE WERE SHOCKED, UNITED STATES,
EUROPE, EVEN UKRAINE EXPLAIN THE
FELLOW EXPERT AT THE ATLANTIC
COUNCIL.
"THE HEAD OF GERMAN INTELLIGENCE
WAS SO CAUGHT OFF GUARD THAT HE
STILL IN KEY EVAN HAD TO BE
EVACUATED
IN THE KYIV AND HAD TO BE
EVACUATED."
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN TALKING IN A
VERY LOUD VOICE OF A POTENTIAL
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
SEEMED PREPARED FOR IT.
NOBODY IN WASHINGTON EVEN BIDEN
HIMSELF REALLY THOUGHT IT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND WHEN IT DID HAPPEN, AN
OFFICIAL CONCLUDED THAT PUTIN
MUST BE INSANE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE IS A
REASON, A GOOD REASON NONE OF US
SAW THIS COMING.
BIDEN JUST SNAPPED.
HE'S A RATIONAL AND IMPOSSIBLE
TO PREDICT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE TOOK IT AT FACE
VALUE.
IT WAS SELF EXCULPATORY, MORE
THAN AN EXCUSE THAN AN ANALYSIS.
PUTIN MAY BE CRAZY BUT IT SAFE
TO ASSUME THAT THERE'S MORE TO
THE INVASION OF UKRAINE THEN A
SINGLE PSYCHIATRIC EPISODE AND
AT THIS POINT IT WOULD BE NICE
TO KNOW WHAT IT IS.
WHY DID THE RUSSIANS DO THIS.
IT'S NOT TREASONOUS TO ASK THAT.
IT'S ESSENTIAL.
YOU CAN'T MAKE WISE DECISIONS
ABOUT THE FUTURE WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING WHAT JUST
HAPPENED.
BUT OUR LEADERS SO FAR HAS
REFUSED TO DO THAT.
THEY KEEP LYING TO THEMSELVES.
IMPOSING CENSORSHIP ON THE REST
OF US.
CHILDISH SLOGANS ABOUT GOOD
VERSUS EVIL.
IT'S INSULTING.
BUT WORSE, IT'S NOT HELPFUL.
THIS IS NOT HOW NATIONS SURVIVE
COMPLEX MOMENTS LIKE THIS.
CRISIS DEMANDS CRYSTAL CLEAR
THINKING.
SO NOW IS A MOMENT TO IGNORE THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENTLY WRONG AND INSTEAD
LISTEN CAREFULLY TO THE PEOPLE
WHO'VE GOTTEN IT RIGHT TO THE
PAST.
THE ONES WHO SAW THE UKRAINE WAR
COMING AND SAID SO OUT LOUD.
THERE WAS OF THE PEOPLE YOU
SHOULD BE LISTENING TO AND ONE
OF THEM IS NIGEL FARAGE.
NOBODY WOULD CALL
HE'S A NATURALIST, HE CARES
ABOUT HIS OWN COUNTRY.
HIS COUNTRY IS GREAT BRITAIN,
THE SAME IS TRUE AND VIRTUALLY
OF OUR COUNTRY.
THE U.S. HAS NEVER HAD A
PRESIDENT AS RECKLESS AS
JOE BIDEN IS.
BUT NIGEL FARAGE COULD'VE
PREDICTED ALL OF THIS.
HE DID PREDICT IT, BACK IN 2014
AS THE LEADER OF THE U.K.
INDEPENDENCE PARTY.
GAVE A SPEECH TO THE EUROPEAN
PARLIAMENT THAT YEAR WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY WE JUST SAW
YESTERDAY.
IN RETROSPECT, HIS WORDS SEEM
PROPHETIC.
FARAGE UNDERSTOOD WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN BECAUSE HE ALREADY SAW
WOULD BE TAKING PLACE.
I THINK YOU'LL AGREE IT'S AN
ELASTIC
ANALYSIS WORTH HAVING.
THIS IS NOW FARAJ ON UKRAINE.
SPEAK OF THE CONTRADICTIONS OF
THE LAST FEW YEARS INCLUDING THE
BOMBING OF LIBYA, THE DESIRE TO
ARM THE REBELS IN SYRIA, HAS
BEEN THE UNNECESSARY PROVOCATION
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THIS E.U. EMPIRE EVER SEEKING TO
EXPAND STATED IT'S TERRITORIAL
CLAIM ON UKRAINE SOME YEARS AGO.
TO MAKE THAT WORSE, OF COURSE,
SOME NATO MEMBERS SAID THAT THEY
TOO WOULD LIKE UKRAINE TO JOIN
NATO.
WE DIRECTLY ENCOURAGED THE
UPRISING IN THE UKRAINE THAT LED
TO THE TOPPLING OF THE PRESIDENT
AND THAT LED OF COURSE IN TURNED
TO VLADIMIR PUTIN REACTING.
THE MORAL OF THE STORY IS IF YOU
POKE THE RUSSIAN BEAR WITH THE
STICK, DON'T BE SURPRISED WHEN
HE REACTS.
NOW JUST TO CONTINUE WITH THAT,
TODAY WE ARE RUSHING THROUGH AN
ASSOCIATION AGREEMENT, WITH
UKRAINE, AND AS WE SPEAK THERE
ARE NATO SOLDIERS ENGAGED IN
MOST EXERCISES IN THE UKRAINE.
HAVE WE TAKEN THE LEAD OF OUR
SENSES?
DO WE ACTUALLY WANT TO HAVE A
WAR WITH PUTIN?
IF WE DO, WE ARE CERTAINLY GOING
ABOUT IT THE RIGHT WAY.
PERHAPS WE OUGHT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE WEST NOW FACES THE
BIGGEST THREAT IN CRISIS TO OUR
WAY OF LIFE THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
OVER 70 YEARS.
THE REASON BEHEADINGS OF BRITISH
AND AMERICAN HOSTAGES
GRAPHICALLY ILLUSTRATES THE
PROBLEM.
WE HAVE OUR OWN CITIZENS FROM
OUR OWN COUNTRIES ENGAGED IN
THAT STRUGGLE TOO.
VLADIMIR PUTIN, WHATEVER WE MAY
THINK OF HIM AS A HUMAN BEING,
IS ACTUALLY ON OUR SIDE.
I SUGGEST WE GROW UP.
I SUGGEST WE RECOGNIZE THE REAL
THREAT FACING ALL OF OUR
COUNTRIES, COMMUNITIES, AND
SOCIETIES.
WE STOP PLAYING WAR GAMES IN THE
UKRAINE.
WE START TO PREPARE A PLAN TO
HELP COUNTRIES LIKE SYRIA, LIKE
IRAQ, LIKE KENYA, LIKE NIGERIA
TO TRY TO HELP THEM TO DEAL WITH
THE REAL THREAT T